please recall I really don't even need
this please recall that because we did
not have a quorum at our last meeting
the meeting was not adjourned we could
not have a motion to adjourn instead we
recessed so I'm going to call that
meeting back into session and note that
we do not yet have a quorum and I
believe that representative Cannon will
appear probably within about 30 minutes
I'm hoping that we can have our business
accomplished by then and send her out
for coffee I do you have the uh a hard
copy of the report
in your hands please forgive me for
a very serious Omission in the list of
members of the committee
because they were late appointments I
neglected to add Representatives Betty
gay and representative Jerry Cannon I
will fix that
and at that point this will be my uh
final report
for this morning uh I would like to
solicit a response from representative
Woods
he has been formative
in
reorienting this subcommittee in its
assessment of precision I'm going to add
a term here Precision medicine and
biomarkers I defer to his wisdom and I'm
very grateful for it and then I'm going
to ask if there are further comments
but given that we are probably not going
to have a quarter I'm confident that we
won't
at that point we'll make whatever
changes are recommended by those present
and we will submit this to the oversight
committee as the completion of our work
which means not another meeting so with
that I'm going to turn to representative
yeah make one quick comment
um given given that uh representative
Cannon is probably at least 30 minutes
out and that we could wrap up before
then should somebody kind of try to
contact her and say hey don't bother did
that oh okay it sounded like she was
well
um I I'll offer a few comments uh the
debatable classification as wisdom
remains to be seen
um
uh one of the things that we talked
about
um is in in Precision medicine uh was
the application of the normal medical
process of I.E having the gold standard
of
um double blind studies and having
um a Cadre of uh participants in that
study with a number large enough to have
a meaningful outcome with p-values of
appropriate Etc
knowing that the
um
nature of quotes Precision or
personalized medicine however you wanted
to find that would not meet that gold
standard
and that raised some issues as exactly
what we as a committee might be able to
do
being constrained
with a normal scientific process which
would not pass muster with first of all
the medical society and certainly the
larger scientific community
thank you
how to how to proceed and still uh as a
legislative body uh be aware uh be
advised and be an educator for not only
the legislators but also for the public
how could how could we possibly go
forward
um
the idea of of of
having some kind of oversight
and awareness on the part of the
legislature I think is critically
important and as I pointed out in my
comments I think in our first session
we've been burned a couple times
nationally and once specifically in New
Hampshire I.E bone marrow transplants
for treating breast cancer and we don't
want to fall into that Gap again
uh the issue came up of looking at
biomarkers
as a subgroup of precision medicine
uh well what are biomarkers biomarkers
are
a indicator and an individual that they
have some element of either a defect
generally chemically or at the molecular
level
and that brings into play of one of my
favorite topics
nanomedicine and nanotechnology
um
I used to have a dog and pony shows I
did around the Northeast and nationally
for the AMA about this and
predicted that this would be the
medicine of the future that was about
gosh it's been 10 years ago now anyway
that is very concrete science
and the way that works is you do a study
and you take some serum or a cell and
you examined the molecular properties of
it
and with
very well documented uh sort of middle
of the road science
and you can say with precision
I'm throwing that word in potentially
that in fact that person does have or
does not have
a particular entity
and we're it we we do this all the time
um probably one of the earliest was
um I don't know States still do it but
you still have to have a syphilis test
to get married
if you've had chickenpox you might get
shingles
and you can test to see if you have
that's a biomarker but it's a very
concrete
test using just vanilla everyday middle
of the road
with nanotechnology you can get down not
but even farther down you can get down
to the What's called the ATO range
uh so you're getting close to being able
to detect if a person has even one or
two molecules in their system
regarding a particular entity you can
probably detected
again with known science
and with application
and some of the early studies as an
example was a study that in mice
prostate cancer
uh they generated a mouse strain and had
prostate cancer and they were able to
detect
uh which ones were and which ones were
none and they designed
a particular molecule
a nanoparticle Gotta Throw That Word in
there again
designed a nanoparticle that would
and was designed in a way that it would
release
a particular in this case a metallic
iron into the cell
and then metallic they use a magnetic
field to heat it
like a microwave in microwave oven so to
using standard techniques
very well known
and that's
sort of the end point for biomarkers
again you don't have you know in in a
study double-blind study of thousands in
your testing and you're giving a
medication which you think may work
you're going at the other end and saying
we know this we can prove that this is a
cancer cell and we know that this
particular molecule will kill that
cancer cell and we've designed this
molecule to get to do just that
now that sounds pretty straightforward
you know just take one out of this
bottle and put it in this bottle and
you're all done
but you still have there's still
criteria that have to be followed and
that that criteria in general form is is
like the criteria for a medication
you say well gee I've got this new
medication and it works wonderfully
uh well like I'll back up and give you
an example of a a penicillin appearance
Allen penicillin first came on the
market
wow this is not good in the lab it
killed all the organisms great
Churchill was one of the first to get it
actually
long story behind that
but carries out they weren't allergic to
the penicillin they were allergic to the
molecule that the penicillin was
attached to
and for the FDA to pass a medication
it has to be number one chemically pure
in other words you can you can't just
have it as we when you make a molecule
in the lab he might make some other side
species
uh of a molecules which may not be so
good
so when you make it you got to make it
sort of
99.99 pure so to speak as the old Ivory
soap commercial said
it used to be biologically compatible
it may be pure but you put it in
biologic system and it reacts because
like the penicillin initially did so
that's Criterion number two
criteria number three
it has to have efficacy
it has to be able to do something once
it gets there so it has to be pure
has to be biologically compatible and
then it has to do what it's supposed to
do
those are the basic overall outline
using biomarkers
okay you still have that same make sure
that that molecule that you're making to
run after a specific cell and attach to
that cell it still has to have all of
these others so it's
there are things that have to be
considered but
you don't have to have 10 000 people in
your study to be able to do it
and that's the difference
and in fact we are getting medicine is
getting more and more in that direction
and as such after my academic
introduction I really don't call I
haven't gone 35 minutes yet have I yeah
okay well I don't qualify for an
academic introduction but
I think that's the direction that I
think this committee can legitimately
approach
the mechanism how that's done under the
oversight committee or some other agency
outlined I think remains but I I think
it would be that would be the direction
I think it would be very much
worthwhile thank you
thank you so much
um we do have a couple of changes to the
draft one as I've mentioned is to add
representative Gay's name representative
Cannon's name we had a in the draft
um the draft recommends that the
oversight committee form a task force
on emerging medical Technologies to meet
at minimum once per year and then at the
call of the chair
um I did get a communication from
representative Merchant suggesting that
that be changed to at least twice per
year rather than once per year and at
the call of the chair is there any
comment on that
okay
I I think uh representative Merchants
um observation that two times a year
might be more appropriate is already
covered in the language that you've
written uh it's at least once per year
and at the call of the chair so if the
chair thinks their second meeting is
needed or third meeting or a fourth
meeting you know that that's all within
the scope of authority of the chair so I
I don't know that I would change what
you've written to say two meetings I'd
leave it at one knowing that a second
one could be convened uh as needed
thank you
further comments on the draft
please go oh okay so I'm I'm looking at
the recommendation uh section and I I
like it I just want to point out what it
what it says because I'm I'm gonna talk
to the detail inside the body now in the
middle of that recommendation there's a
sentence the commission shall scan
emerging medical Technologies to assess
whether any of these Technologies Merit
detailed oversight I love it
and then
on page three there's a paragraph a sub
paragraph Alpha and Bravo and basically
what what this paragraph is doing is
it's identifying that we've got a need
for this committee to look at Precision
medicine and biomarkers it it feels to
me like this paragraph would benefit
from another sub-paragraph Charlie C
that would read something like medical
Technologies includes but is not limited
to Precision medicine and biomarkers the
full range of medical technology may be
expanded include things such as
artificial intelligence man-made organs
for transplant emerging functional and
structural Imaging among others so so I
it isn't meant to be an exhaustive list
but just an idea that we don't know what
we don't know yet about the future of
emerging technology and so whatever this
committee does it should I think have a
more open view on what may come into its
purview
uh thank you a couple of comments
one can you please email me that
verbiage I'd be very grateful for that
okay okay secondly
um I'd like to comment on what I think
is a key Insight
then that is the use of both artificial
intelligence and artificial organs and
artificial intelligence is of course a
burgeoning area and I totally agree that
we ought to at least pay homage to that
but
New Hampshire is in the process of
becoming the national Center for created
organ systems uh as you know we have a
substantial Grant from the Department of
Defense that has gone to a Consortium of
organizations I'm going to say led by
and that is my interpretation uh uh DACA
uh Dean cayman's organization in
Manchester and they are developing the
technology for uh created organs I think
it's a very very good idea to include
that uh within our verbiage so I'm
grateful for that
um
yeah so it sounds to me like you're open
to some paragraph Charlie as I read it
and I'll send it to you and it so if we
do that then
um on page two the the First full
paragraph that starts with Medical
Technology
there's a sentence that says this
requires that as technology changes it
is a state responsibility to assess its
role in facilitating development
and distribution of preventive and
Curative Technologies I I would just ask
you if you think we might want to before
the word preventative insert the word
diagnostic or are we not wanting to look
at emerging technology that has only a
diagnostic value
uh I think that's an important idea
addition I'd be very happy with that
okay I'll send that to you as well
that's already in there okay no we're
not diagnostic you just wrote the word I
just Instagram my note yes sir and and
then the task for shall and then it says
Alpha so this is our task it said that
we're just illicit definitions of Bio
testing Precision medicine did are those
definitions in the appendix I don't
recall the appendix if it had those I
mean we we did I think no get good
definitions that we could be reporting
out I believe the definitions are not in
there uh the definitions were waiting
for testimony from the experts that we
had lined up uh but we changed our Focus
uh with uh representative Woods guidance
from uh Precision medicine to biomarker
testing and we've written this report
without having that testimony and so
this would
place the burden of responsibility for
developing those definitions on the task
force that emerges shouldn't emerge
should there be an LSR
okay so we just don't put a check mark
as completed because this because that
paragraph of the task force shall tend
to be our homework assignment and we we
decided that we didn't need to do that
right okay thank you
further comments
oh yes representative Woods oh yes I I
would agree with the comments I I would
just uh in terms of the term
Technologies
um in in the
in the academic world and in the
commercial world the term technology
includes Ai and and so in this sense but
I think it's worthwhile as an effort to
parse that out specifically but in the
in the academic and in the academic
world the technology and if you read
some of the literature it's um something
called hard technology versus soft
Technologies uh but it's it's really is
included
um and again not not say that we
shouldn't I think it's important that
that might be added for those who are
reading the report uh and uh looking to
what we would cover uh to make sure that
that's that is and brought out and um in
the same way for uh preventive and
Curative Technologies adding Diagnostics
that preventive making a diagnosis in by
implication as a preventive measure
um but I think to make that spec make
that specific uh I think is is also good
so I appreciate you I appreciate the
additions you know as an ex-radiology
administrator who fed my family from
that I'd like doing a shout out to
Diagnostic Imaging from time to time so
yeah
if you will email me changes if you have
specific wording that you want in
um I will make those changes and I will
submit this draft uh to the oversight
committee and I will recess this meeting
um and I am not calling a follow-up
meeting ladies and gentlemen thank you
foreign
this
a
you know this is a very exciting time of
mine
all right
I'm opening the meeting of the
subcommittee on transparency a
subcommittee appointed uh last month by
The Joint legislative DHHS oversight
committee
and
just a review and the reason I'm
reviewing is documents have come to in
some cases me and other cases the
members of the committee which uh
evidence the individuals have jumped in
quite late
so let me just very quickly review what
we hope to do
we hope to protect the public
by disclosing egregious conduct on the
part of medical professionals
and we also want to protect the good
professionals and hospitals from
something that may be misinterpreted as
bad conduct when in fact it wasn't
I received an email this morning from Dr
Molly rosignal
and she is the medical director of the
New Hampshire professionals health
program and they as as I
um as chief chief executive officer of a
small Medical Counseling Center want to
make sure that the mental health of our
providers is adequately looked after
especially in the light of what may be
false accusations so we want to get it
right for everybody
simultaneously to this subcommittee
there was an investigation by the
Attorney General's office to see if laws
were broken in reporting or
non-reporting over the last several
months they're not ready to come forward
with anything at this time they suspect
it may be
two to four weeks
also simultaneously a South Senate Bill
330 the relationship with oplc office of
professional licensure and
see
certification and various organizations
they oversee
the purpose of this group here is to
find the best way to get all of this
done
who reports who may report complaints
how do they do it who evaluates the
complaints and at what level is
something made public
and I would like to First Call on
Lindsay Courtney if you would come up to
say a little bit about the relationship
between oplc and the Board of Medicine
on this issue
thank you good afternoon Representative
members of the committee for the record
Wednesday Courtney executive director
New Hampshire office of professional Ace
insurance certification
so in terms of the relationship between
the boards and the office the office was
created in 2015 through a budget trailer
process under Governor Hassan to provide
administrative support to all of our
licensing boards
um so plainly speaking the boards the
office is the primary location for all
of the boards they do not have separate
staff they do not have separate funding
they do not have a separate location
everything is run through the office in
terms of funding and administrative
support we have one website by way we
provide by by through which we provide
Communications and web support for all
of the boards but everything is run
through the office for each
board
happy to answer any more questions with
respect to that issue but basically any
function that is Administrative in
nature is performed by the office on
behalf of all of the boards in
accordance with the regulations that are
propagated by that board
this is why people who have a complaint
and go to the board of medicines website
are immediately directed to oplc yes
yes that's correct there are no board
there are no employees employed by each
board the board members are not
physically at the office unless they are
meeting
um personally 1091a therefore the staff
that are in receipt of that information
are from the office additionally we have
been charged under RSA 310a with trying
to streamline the processes and
procedures including those procedures as
it relates to investigations and receipt
of complaints part of providing
efficient and economic Services which is
our mission in RSA 310a is to ensure
that we do not have 54 different ways of
doing business which was historically
the case prior to the office's creation
so recently I want I think it was in
2019 representative we sought additional
statutory authority to probably
investigative rules at the office level
those rules were recently promulgated
RPS PLC 200s which direct that
complaints be filed with the office
let's suppose somebody goes to the Board
of Medicine website with a complaint is
directed over to oplc what happens next
so if I received a complaint
um it's screened in by our intake staff
member who assesses whether or not it
could constitute an emergency if it
could constitute an emergency
posing an imminent danger to your you
know Public Safety health or welfare
um that is elevated up to the
investigative bureau's Chief bureau
chief who makes an assessment in
consultation
um with the physician staff investigator
and they decide whether or not to
conduct an expedited investigation we
don't act just on receipt of a complaint
at least some information needs to be
verified because people do file
complaints that turn out to be frivolous
so once the information is verified at
an emergency nature if it's decided that
um that the issue could constitute an
emergency the board chair is notified
only the board chair has the authority
to call an emergency meeting if the
board chair decides to call an emergency
meeting the board considers whether or
not to emergency suspend somebody's
license on the flip side if it's not an
emergency then it goes in essentially in
the queue
it's logged in as a complaint it's
assigned to a staff investigator
as well as the physician investigator so
I'll there's two separate processes I
should say there's the process for the
Board of Medicine and there's a process
for every other board the Board of
Medicine is unique in that it has the
statutory medical review subcommittee
every other board with the exception of
them I should say the board of mental
health practice has a professional
conduct committee but every other board
under the office we receive a complaint
we log it it's assigned to a staff
investigator who works the case up free
of your staff of my staff yep
and they're trained investigators if
it's assessed during the course of the
investigation that expertise is
warranted then
um typically a board member will recuse
him or herself to provide that expertise
or we
um reach out to a consultant we retain a
consultant to provide that level of
expertise
the staff member will
complete the investigation draft up a
report of investigation and submit that
to the board the board will make a
decision as to whether or not which
board
any other word other than other than the
Board of Medicine the Board of Medicine
has a different process all right I want
to know about that but I think
I'm getting their representative I think
it's important to understand how things
generally operate within the office so
you can make an assessment as to you
know what the process should be moving
forward
so the board will make a decision after
receiving a report of Investigation as
to whether or not additional information
is warranted the case should be
dismissed or the case should received a
disciplinary action if the case is to
proceed to disciplinary the case is
handed off to a prosecutor who
prosecutes the case
now with respect to the Board of
Medicine
case comes in it gets logged in
essentially The Physician investigator
is required under their rules to make an
assessment as to whether or not the case
is facially valid meaning whether the
case States a claim
um if the case does not State a claim
the rules require and the statute
requires that it go to the Board of
Medicine the Board of Medicine can make
a decision to dismiss the case or refer
to the medical review subcommittee which
is a statutory body comprised of
volunteer Physicians and public members
to oversee investigations under the
Board of Medicine
if the physician investigator decides
that it does State a claim the physician
investigator working with the chair of
the medical review subcommittee assigns
medical review subcommittee physician
member or public member to oversee and
investigate that case
we are able to provide and we do provide
staff assistance but essentially the
member of the medical review
subcommittee
controls the case they manage that case
they dropped up the ROI which is what I
spoke of earlier the report of
Investigation
um which once complete is provided to
the entire medical review subcommittee
which then
um makes a recommendation for someone to
a vote to the Board of Medicine as to
whether to dismiss or to proceed to
disciplinary action and then it falls
follows the same process for every other
board
question representative Edwards uh okay
so thank you Ms Courtney that was a
really nice description of the
underlying data flow and it was so
precise I was imagining as you were
talking that there's a flowchart
documenting what you just said
and if so could you provide us a copy of
that flow chart or if you haven't
already yes absolutely representative
okay uh thank you for that
um
also as you were talking about the data
flow
um I was drifting off into one of my
pastimes years ago of worrying about the
user interface with with websites and so
I'm just curious
um when somebody wants to make a
complaint of Board of Medicine
complaints specifically
when they navigate in to make a
complaint
is the user experience one or they
believe that they're talking to the
Board of Medicine or it doesn't appear
as though it's a
standard bureaucratic this is the oplc
we handle everything from cats to zebras
it's it's hard to assess what the user
believes I think oftentimes
the oplc is fairly young I think most
people don't really understand what we
do on behalf of the boards and there's
putting aside the investigations and
complaints
um
reason to interface with their office I
think there's a often a misunderstanding
on the part of the consumer that when
they come to our office they talk to
somebody
they can believe that they're speaking
with the Board of Medicine Real Estate
Commission yada yada
um in reality I think I mean that's not
supposed to happen ever you know that
you just be able to talk to a member of
the board because the board can only
collectively act collectively a pursue
into a quorum
um I think if if they file a complaint
through our website it's it's going to
be a fairly obvious to most users that
they are filing it with the office and
there's some information on our website
that sets forth the investigations flow
so what if I were to say that I think it
would be important from the user
perspective that when they go in there
with the idea that they're reporting to
the Board of Medicine that the splash
splash screens and the images and the
words look to them like they're
interacting with the Board of Medicine
instead of something they don't
understand the oplc
one that that's my theory that people
would have more confidence that they're
reporting properly and therefore would
go all the way sort of a complaint
process
and two that that the design of the
website can be set up so that the splash
screens can help create that look and
feel that's my theory what what how do
you react to that
well I don't think we have a reporting
problem
um I I think people are able to make
complaints
at the board of nursing I just went over
the statistics last night we received a
little over 200 complaints for the Board
of Nursing last year somewhere in the
realm of 170 I can get you the precise
numbers for the Board of Medicine
um
so I guess I would so I don't think that
people are afraid to report
um if that's the case then certainly we
should explore modifications to our
website but also communication
strategies but at the end of the day the
office's obligation is to provide that
service so I'm not sure that changing
the way we look is the best approach it
may just be educating the end user as to
what our
um our role is in this process
with the flow chart we requested bear
striking similarity to this that does
appear to be
the one maybe that I had forwarded to
your previously representative but I
can't see that far away I apologize I
keep talking I I would say it probably
is but this is a very top level uh
workflow and and you were being much
more precise about all the branch
conditions if this than this if this and
that would and your your description was
like within the Board of Medicine
specifically what the workflow is and
and that's what I'm really asking for
because I think while this is a nice
graphic it really doesn't get us very
far yes I I can certainly provide that
micro level detail
um to you and I do believe we have a
slide already that I can forward to
representative
um that's it for my questions thank you
I would however suggest that when
a complaintant access is the board of
medicine's website the complaintant is
not just directed to oplc but there's a
brief explanation that this is how the
complaint will be heard and dealt with
because I didn't see that and I'm saying
how come it's going over there
so a simple sentence I think would
alleviate
um at least concerns like that certainly
Mr chair I did think yeah go ahead okay
so your your description of the workflow
was pretty detailed and precise but what
I did not hear was uh any feedback going
to the original person who made the
complaint and so if we were trying to
build a closed-loop system whoever is
initiating the process would also get
some sort of feedback to let them know
what the resolution was do you believe
that we have that embedded in the in the
web technology to give them feedback
that the investigation has been complete
and here's our determination
so not in the technology and I think
this is
um
a
a point that an issue that I think this
legislature needs to consider so
um
the statutes do not most statutes and
they're all different but most statutes
within our boards do not permit us to
disclose information about an ongoing
investigation to anyone including the
complainant and so that
um that is problematic
um
from a public protection standpoint
consumer
providing good customer service we we
are not permitted to give information
unless and until there is a final
disposition
there are some exceptions to that in
certain and I don't know the Board of
Medicine off the top of my head if the
prosecutor is going to be negotiating a
settlement there is typically an
opportunity for the complainant to
comment on the settlement and certain
board statutes that's not true for all
of them
so from my perspective uh it would be
helpful for us to have the authority to
be able to share at least procedural
information with a complainant yeah we
receive your complaint it's at this
stage of the process
um because that is the those are the
more frequent inquiries we receive to
our enforcement division
do you have the authority now to go back
to the complainant and say thank you so
much for making a complaint
we've received it yeah we can
acknowledge receipt okay correct what we
can't do is say you know somebody calls
up and said oh it's been five months
where is it on the process
I can just say thank you yes we receive
we have your complaint right and I
wouldn't encourage uh in progress
reviews back to the complaint but at
some point the case is closed and the
determination has been made so what I'm
referring to is just closing it out with
the complainant on what the final
determination of their complaint was is
is that possible do you have the
authority to do that yes and we do so if
the board decides to dismiss a case
um two letters go out one goes to the
physician one goes to the complainant
um if the board decides to dismiss with
a letter of concern the letter of
concern goes to the physician and just a
basic letter goes to the complainant
that does not reference the letter of
concern and then obviously if it
proceeds to disciplinary they're
notified you know notice of hearing is
public
words in your mouth but as I I hear you
talk through that whole closed loop
system with a complaintant it sounds to
me like you're saying that you believe
it is adequate that it is it's supported
and it's being uh supported yes I will
say though that though there is a hole
in that system
um with respect to medical malpractice
cases and with reports because
we received an I can speak to this on
different sides of being a former
plaintiff's lawyer and being an
administrative
um side when we received a complaint
when the when the office receives a
complaint a lawsuit that's been filed
from the court
the complainment is not considered to be
the person who filed the lawsuit the
complainant is the court
and I can tell you from my perspective
my former life that wasn't readily
apparent to me
um and I felt that I'm filing this
lawsuit I should be considered the
complainant and I'm going to be
receiving some feedback that's not the
case so
um that would be the ones you know the
type of circumstances in which the
individual who filed a lawsuit would not
receive any notification as to whether
or not uh the case has been dismissed or
has proceeded to disciplinary action and
I don't think that connects with what
the expectation is in the field and I'm
sure others can can
okay so we're all here okay so um to
play devil's advocate for the status quo
um the the complaint in a malpractice
case they will get their feedback uh or
just or disposition based on how the
court case that they initiated uh is
determined they they haven't voiced an
interest in having the physician
disciplines what they're looking for is
to be made whole again so so why would
the Board of Medicine necessarily have a
duty to inform somebody who initiated a
lawsuit if they already know when the
lawsuit's been concluded why why would
they care what the Board of Medicine did
with that information
well I think because there is this
expectation knowing that the court
automatically forwards the complaint
over to the office for consideration I
think we received fewer consumer
complaints that are arising at if not
cases that are also leading to
malpractice cases because there is that
understanding that you know why would I
duplicate efforts
um
that's just my view of potentially what
could be happening here and obviously we
don't want to duplicate work
um but I can tell you what I used to
practice uh I had no idea that
um that we you know that I was not being
through you know my client was not being
treated as the complainant
um and you know I think if I had known
that I probably would have purposely
gone out of my way to our specifically
uh before I call on anyone else
um he I wrote down if there's an
emergency that is shuffled off to I
don't mean that pejoratively it goes
over to oplc you say the board chair of
the Board of Medicine is notified and
may then proceed and I want to nail that
word down may not must
if you deem it's to be an emergency
and then they're notified
right now they may go forward or they
may not
so that's one of the words we've been
playing around with along the way I just
wanted to make sure I heard you
correctly yes that's correct okay
representative Weber I have a process
question for the chair if I may it seems
to me that we are re-plowing
um ground that we have already plowed
and I came today prepared to deal with a
final report and it's my understanding
that we now have several other people
who are going to testify
back to the process
so I am wondering what your plan is for
all of this and I'm going to
um State you might need to leave it free
of my apologies
when that happens because it sounds to
me we've got more than one meeting's
worth of work if we're if we're starting
over again for stuff that I think we've
already heard a fair amount about
yes and to answer your question that is
what I intend to do is to reply and the
reason for that is everybody
or numbers of people stated what they
wanted to say then they went off and
thought about it because they hurt each
other then they looked at at least three
iterations of the report from
representative Solway and now they're
coming back with some more so yeah we
kind of are redoing it
and this will be the last meeting of
this group I believe I think we're done
and from this meeting I suspect some of
us will want to work together on our own
simply as legislators to craft an LSR
based on this
well thank you for that
um
any other questions for
well thank you and we'll look forward to
that document thank you for your time
and this one very important test hurdle
you must pass
and you're dead
turning the mic on exactly perfect yeah
um
I'm David Conway I'm a retired OB GYN
I'm the current position investigator
for the Board of Medicine I am employed
by oplc
um I was
a member of the medical review
subcommittee from 2010 to 2016 and a
member of the board from 2017 until this
past May when I resigned to take this
position
at opl Seattle oplc
but you were on the Board of Medicine
yes president for the last year and a
half
um to I'm sorry you are representative
Edwards Edwards and I just want to
address your question about the flow
chart
um you all should have a copy of it in
your email and there are several copies
floating around here this is your chart
that's my tryout yep so so you heard
that this is necessary but not
sufficient she went into great detail
that is sufficient for the process that
I go through okay okay I believe
and I'm going to kind of get to that
after reading the draft or the oversight
committee I want to clarify the process
the board actually goes through to
investigate consumer complaints
complaints by other licensees
lawsuits out-of-state actions and so on
um I am no longer a member of the board
I cannot I'm not here as a
representative of the board uh simply as
a an individual licensee who has a lot
of experience with the investigations
the board does
um
there's been a lot of talk about the May
and shall investigate language and I
want to emphasize that every single
complaint whether it's a lawsuit whether
it's Consumer complaint whatever
is investigated
and the process starts with a complaint
coming into the board that's initially
reviewed by an investigator there
and in consultation with me I decide I
basically triage that to determine is
this an emergency
um
is this no further action uh frivolous
or unfounded
if I make any of those determinations it
goes directly to the board
so that the chairman of the board can
call an emergency
a meeting for possible emergency
suspension
if
um any of those go to the board and they
say no this is not an emergency this is
not we don't think this is no further
action there needs to be some
investigation then it's sent to the
medical review subcommittee to do a more
in-depth investigation
when that complaint initially comes in a
response is required is requested from
the licensee so that I am looking at the
complaint that is in front of me as well
um
that you can read through the rest of
this it should be in your mailboxes
um
looking at the statistics from 2016 to
2019 which were kept by a previous
investigator
um roughly 80 percent were found to be
unfounded or no further action 16 were
letters of concern and three percent
um
Miss Courtney uh did go through the uh
different steps that could be taken
doctor because you are masked would you
speak much closer to the mic please yes
and I'm sorry I'm just locating my place
once it goes to the Medical Group
subcommittee
um and is assigned to a member or to an
outside reviewer if they're we need
somebody who has more expertise than
somebody on the medical view
subcommittee uh report is
generated that goes to the entire
committee at the following meeting to
decide uh whether it
needs to be no further action whether it
needs a letter of concern whether it
needs discipline
and that recommendation goes to the
board
and the board can either agree with that
recommendation or recommend either
lesser intervention or greater
intervention
um
I did want to address
some comments uh about
listings settled malpractice lawsuits On
The Board website and I don't think
that's appropriate I think that it's an
invasion of
privacy where that lawsuit was found not
to be
the standard of care
um
that lawsuits arise for a variety of
reasons outside of their being poor
practice just because it's a bad outcome
doesn't mean there was bad medicine
and there was some kind of examples that
I stated initially at the last meeting
as far as things that I experienced in
my own practice as far as women
presenting in advanced labor
extremely premature with a baby that is
going to be
either not surviving or will have
defects later on in development
or severe shoulder distortions or
someone who presents inactive labor with
life-threatening bleeding
um those are things that you have to
take care of that
[Music]
um
can either go in uh very well or not
well at all there are women there are
patients whose ex patients are not met
and patients who suffer known
complications one has been adequate
informed consent uh chairman Pearson
raised the question of whether the oplc
is the right place for submitting
information and not only comment that
the infrastructure and support that OPC
oplc gives us is essential in order to
do our job
so finally regarding the proposed draft
the board does currently inform the
public of its actions regarding any
provider misconduct which threatens the
quality of care for well or well-being
of patients the board does investigate
any non-voluntary licensed revocations
or suspensions out of state to determine
if reciprocal discipline is warranted
and if so that is also posted on the
website
the board does investigate any
non-voluntary Hospital privilege
revocations or suspensions to determine
if discipline is warranted and if so
that is also posted on the website
um as I noted above the board does not
simply report malpractice suits that are
settled where the standard of care is
met the board investigates those cases
and determines the need for discipline
and any discipline is posted on the
website
um
the board does currently report any New
Hampshire board actions on the website
and investigates out of state board
actions to determine the need for
reciprocal discipline which is then
posted on the website
and I welcome any questions how many
have been posted
in the last oh say five to eight years
because the initial Globe Spotlight team
articles seem to indicate the answer is
zero in New Hampshire
you can go to the website and you can
see all of the actions that the board
has taken well I've not found them where
are they that I'm missing them if you go
if you look at the uh New Hampshire
Board of Medicine yeah
you go down the list and it says board
actions and it goes back I want to say
10 or 15 years
yeah I want to bring in an attorney
Courtney okay two also don't go away we
have a lot of mics here an engineer on
Friday pointed that out to me I didn't
know that I just want to clarify for the
committee that the what is reported are
board actions uh we don't we don't
report malpractice payouts or claims
unless they have resulted in abort
action and what we report is the board
action good I think that that protects
the physician in the hospital from
unwarranted inferences so that's good
but I use do you know offhand
um if we scroll down to board actions
which I guess I haven't done about how
many of them would there have been in
I can estimate it because I go through
those on a regular basis that anywhere
from probably 10 to 25 per year
so so a number of us who investigated
this apparently missed all that because
the statement was made Massachusetts
um
statements about malpractice that were
not specifically broken out to frivolous
or warranted or whatever and New
Hampshire made none so it sounds like
we're all missing the same thing
if if I may
what what Massachusetts is reporting and
I assume I'm making an assumption here
that they interface with the National
Practitioner databake or or something
where they grab the information
regarding malpractice claims and payouts
otherwise they would be manually
entering that information as it's
reported
um they report information that are
malpractice claims we do not we report
board action so if there were 20K
malpractice claims that were on the
medicine website and there were zero in
ours I think one can make the Assumption
um that we didn't take any board actions
that were the results of those claims
I'm wondering if we're
miscommunicating here because what I
think that the chairman may be asking
about is the specific case where there
were 20
um notes
in Massachusetts and none here and I'm
thinking and I hope you will correct me
if I'm wrong that the reason that those
didn't show up here was either because
as you've just said they were the kind
of things that we don't normally report
at this point or because
that practitioner had left practice is
that another reason why you might not
report
I I think I think it would be very
helpful if you could
um in addition to answering the question
generally which is what I think you did
if you are able to answer the question
with respect to that specific case it
would help us very much thank you thank
you representative I cannot offer any
specific information on that particular
individual because the board did not
take public disciplinary action against
that individual what Massachusetts
reports is not only their board
decisions on disciplinary action but
they also report General malpractice
claims and payouts that second piece is
something we do not report
foreign
thank you that's very helpful
representative Edwards I don't know who
answers this it's on the uh the flow
chart that we've all agreed that we have
um there's I this is a nerd alert
we have a line here an abandoned line
that goes that's above Roi
and Below Board of Medicine and it
doesn't have an arrow it's got to have
an arrow or people like me go insane
hello
um you can put the arrow going towards
the Board of Medicine and I apologize
for the typo no sweat
um if I weren't OCD I wouldn't even
noticed what what is an Roi in this case
Board of Investigation
that reported watch of Investigation
okay thank you when a case goes to the
mrsc a report is generated that
describes the case uh describes the
response of the licensee uh and it
assessment made by the reviewer for
recommendations
foreign
Pearson I also I just so you know I
forwarded you the flowchart
um that details a little bit
um on a micro level the process that I
outlined it's in your email inbox yes
thank you representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman and thank you once again
for being here and testimony
um I'm just trying to make it clear in
my mind what is reported on the website
unlike me and I understand that if it's
a board action of any sort of
disciplinary action that it ends up on
the website
so the two circumstances if you had a
provider of any sort that had a
malpractice suit settled for whatever
reason but you found that there was no
malpractice
that does not show up on the website
correct correct does it show up that
they had a settlement or a malpractice
suit in any way shape or form on the
website no
if you had a provider that had a
malpractice suit that was actually found
to be a true malpractice event quality
of care ethical issues and a board of
action is then taken that shows up on
the website is there any other asterisk
that said there was also an attendant to
this a lawsuit that was settled or does
lawsuit not show up at all on your
website it does not show up okay thank
you
I I would add though that typically if
it was the result if a board
disciplinary decision was the result of
a lawsuit that when you read The
Narrative order it likely will include
what level of discipline is needed
before it will show up
there are several forms of discipline
they all show up one is a reprimand
one is revocation one is suspension or
temporary loss of license uh
uh also providers can be required to
take continuing Medica medical education
uh
I believe there could be a fine you gave
um suspension or is there a category of
light duties like you are still allowed
to practice but what is that called
a restriction a restriction uh we could
require a proctor if a surgeon is has
has multiple complications we could
require that he or she be proctored for
any further surgery is there a day it
must like 30 days um greater or even
I am not sure
um likely it's uh it would be included
in the order that the final order that
delineates the uh uh the discipline as
far as when it needs to
um
go into effect
so I should then be able to go on to the
website and
um
scroll down to board actions
would the board action
list a hospital action
only it's done in-house somebody's on
restricted duties
with the board would have to be notified
by the institution okay so the hospital
would then officially
I don't mean you heard it on the great
fire the hospital would officially have
to notify the board yes that they did
this in-house and if they don't notify
you folks then it it's still you don't
know it correct okay thank you
representative soloway
thank you Mr chairman Dr Conway welcome
back uh let me wish you a happy
Halloween
um so if I get this right and I need
your input on this
the term disciplinary action may require
some definition
so for example a disciplinary action
within a Health Care Organization
might include for example
suspension of privileges restriction of
privileges proctoring mentoring and so
forth but this may not reach the level
of reportability to the board though
that might be considered a disciplinary
action
secondly if I may
if there were to be a settled lawsuit
and insurer May exert its own
disciplinary action by suspending
malpractice insurance by increasing the
premium for that malpractice insurance
and this would also be a disciplinary
action not reportable to the board and
as I if I get this right and I need your
input the only disciplinary actions that
get reported to the public are the
disciplinary actions that are determined
by the Board of Medicine in response to
complaints these other forms of
disciplinary action are not reportable
is that correct correct I have that all
right
that's how we've done it for a long time
yes thank you that's what's required in
the statute thank you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman thank you
again Dr Conley
um just a question of the lens available
to the Board of Medicine
unless you uh so a superior court has to
report filing of any medical injury a
hospital has to report to you any
disciplinary action revocation of
privileges or limitation or privileges
correct a State Medical Society would
have to report to you by Statute any
limitations and privileges or licensing
etc etc right
I don't know about the medical society
so what I'm trying to say if if it was
if it's not for a patient complaint or
family patient complaint you would not
be aware of any problematic behavior in
a hospital a multi-specialty clinic
unless there was some disciplinary
action within the hospital or the
multi-specialty clinic is that correct
because they're not report they're not
required to report entirely the
disruptive Physicians who could be
reported to the Board of Medicine
but are they required from the hospital
to report you know if there's any
suspension of privileges if they did not
do that do they are they required to
show that to report to you there's I
would say no that if there's no action
to affect their uh and I think believe
Mr Anand is here and he can testify to
that
that if there's no action against that
Physician's uh privileges then the
answer would be no you would not see it
correct okay let me try to clarify that
again I'm the token liberal arts here
which is why we have to do these things
three times
um
let's say a hospital puts a physician on
a restriction for 20 days 26 days
whatever
I know the hospital Association will be
far better able to answer this and
they're going to be coming up pretty
soon
are they required
to notify
you
Board of Medicine oplc if they put
someone that works there on restriction
what I understand is yes
they are if they've restricted that
so
then presumably the last time a
physician or surgeon was thus
disciplined
you folks knew it you were told it
a little coaching
uh could you repeat your question
if a physician or surgeon that works at
a particular Hospital
was disciplined by that hospital let's
say put on a 20-day restriction
um you have to have a proctor in the
room or something yeah
must they
inform the Board of Medicine
they need to form the board into the mic
close they need to inform the Board of
Medicine who then decides do we need to
so it could be
that somebody's under a certain level of
discipline at a local hospital
and because the Board of Medicine
chooses not to go any further
the public doesn't hear about it
I'm assuming a local hospital does not
have a place where they report who's
that's an excellent question I would
have to repeat my answer that if a
physician's privileges are restricted
the board has to decide has to be
informed and has to decide if they need
to impose any kind of discipline thank
you
one more time
so I'm I'm with the logical flow here
that the hospitals must report any sort
of disciplinary or restrictions to the
if the Board of Medicine receives a
report from the hospital saying there
has been a restriction
it sounds like the Board of Medicine
hasn't its discretion
the ability to choose to Echo that
restriction and and repeat it or to let
it lie if they leave it alone it does
not become reportable because the Board
of Medicine took no action
I I didn't hear you I'm sorry no
disciplinary action no okay so so I'm
struggling with this because this
doesn't pass the common sense test to me
it seems to me if a hospital has
rendered restrictions of duties or
disciplinary action whatever term you
want to use there
that that becomes of interest to the
public and it seems like even if the
Board of Medicine we're just behaving
like a bull fighter and waving the bull
through the cape you would still want to
report to the public that a lot of bull
is coming through so I'm sorry I used to
push that analogy too far I Blame You Mr
chair uh okay but and but so we're not
so it's it seems to me like there's a
gap in what I would consider the common
sense test
are you hearing me do you agree with me
do you disagree I see a representative
or excuse me uh is Courtney nodding in
the back so you seem to think what I'm
saying makes sense do you want to
comment on it
foreign
I would just say that there are the
Board of Medicine like all regulatory
boards has the discretion whether or not
to and this I think is consistent with
what Dr Baker testified to at the first
hearing they have discretion to decide
whether or not to take disciplinary
action even if on its face the
allegations
um are facially valid so certainly there
could be circumstances in which a
hospital chooses to take action
could I answer so what would be
the disadvantages or the problems in
your view Miss Courtney if the
legislature were to mandate that any
Hospital disciplinary action even if the
Board of Medicine chooses not to to
layer upon their own action that they
still had a duty to report to the public
the hospital's initial action even
though the Board of Medicine chose to do
nothing why why should we not mandate
that
or should we I mean so under your
scenario
whether or not the board took action
the board would be required to report
the information that the hospital took I
guess that's that's
it I I don't know that I can comment on
that I think I would need to think that
through
um I think the question you pose is are
there any valid circumstances under
which that a hospital would would take
action and the board would not
I I also can't answer that question
either
could I add to the conversation so Dr
Conway if you would not
so for instance if there was a
disruptive physician who
um was not interacting with other staff
members at a hospital
over a fairly brief amount of time and
the hospital chose to suspend them for X
number of days or weeks uh whatever that
had to be that has to be reported to
um
the board for investigation during that
investigation
if it turned out that this provider was
going through a divorce had had death in
the family any number of things that
increased stress
a pandemic for instance
um then and this was the first time that
this physician had come before the board
the board could say okay you have
violated the statute and the board has
chosen not to discipline you and that
goes out as a letter of concern
that is confidential
might we take the chart that Miss
Courtney provided
in our it's gosh it was even in the
first part of this month it just seemed
so long ago of various levels of
discipline and say at this level it must
be reported on the website but above it
such as a momentary
rudeness that was dealt with it does not
have to be reported might we find that
happy place where Bad Medicine must be I
don't know why the Board of Medicine
wouldn't report it but no
make a judgment on it but I something's
missing and we're trying to find out
looking at complaints there are
complaints where patients have been
injured for whatever reason through
incompetent practice
through unavoidable complications
there are could be possible discipline
for somebody who has illegible uh
medical records or incomplete medical
records and
uh
again I looking at the examples I
presented for a shoulder dystocia where
it took five or six minutes to deliver a
baby that was basically delivered dead
and was resuscitated
uh and then three years later there was
a lawsuit
um
with uh neurologic delay and an Herb's
palsy that
when a kid doesn't come out there are
only so many things you can do
and doing those things this is something
I was able to affect a delivery and
there was a lawsuit that was involved I
was not named in it but the institution
was and the board asked me to explain my
care of that patient it was a delivery
that I was pulled into at the very last
minute by another provider who couldn't
deliver the baby
and I had to explain my care
what I did uh and the difficulty I had
in delivering that baby and the board
decided boy this is a terrible outcome
and you did everything that you had to
on the one hand we seem to get be
getting farther and farther into the
weeds
on the other hand it seems to me that
there are other people waiting who may
actually be able to answer these
questions better than the folks who are
sitting at the table who I hope would be
available to be come back if we have
further questions in their specialty
afterwards but it seems to me if I can
clarify what we've heard so far there
are two levels of discipline one at that
institutional level and one at the board
level and all discipline
at the institutional level at a certain
level has to be reported to the board
which may or may not take further action
if they did further action it's
reportable if they don't it's not
we can sit here we as a board need as
this group need to decide if more needs
to be done here
and I think that if more needs to be
done there needs to be a specific
exploration
of what level of hospital and
institutional involvement has to be
reported on the website
and that is not a determination that I
am prepared to make today and wrote on
today I think that has to be
something for further action
um so if we could perhaps describe the
way forward but not have to make a final
determination that might help because we
all know that whatever happens we're
going to have to put it into a bill and
that's going to have a hearing and the
subcommittee and all the rest of the
process I agree I'd like to call I'd
like to first of all thank you folks and
now
um who better can speak to the hospitals
than the president of the New Hampshire
Hospital Association so um we I call the
President Steve Allen to come forward
please
foreign
good afternoon
um for the record Steve Allman president
New Hampshire Hospital Association
um so just a few comments and open it up
for questions and discussion
um Mr chairman we certainly
appreciate your
goal that you laid out at the very
beginning of this hearing you've made
that comment several times in public as
well as in private
um I think we would agree with that but
how we do that is the question that we
have in front of us and how we do that
has to balance a lot of those varying
um you know factors and I guess just a
couple of things
um I think this is going to require
ongoing discussion and dialogue as I've
said since these hearings began you know
we want to be a part of this
conversation going forward to ensure
that you know we're doing the right
things but we're also not penalizing
those providers who are doing well and
doing the right things those hospitals
that are doing doing the right things
and I believe you know our members are
working very very hard and I think it
would be helpful if I could just sort of
give a sort of a big picture on a couple
of things you know hospitals take their
responsibility for who practices and who
provide services inside their walls very
very seriously they're governed by the
conditions of participation under
Medicare and Medicaid that require that
hospital boards oversee the clinical
practice within their their institutions
and
the accrediting organizations whether
it's the Joint Commission dnv the CMS
have the authority and the ability when
they come in to review those records to
ensure that they're doing the things
you know it's important to note you have
a hospital with an Administration and a
medical staff overseen by a Board of
Trustees the medical staff is an
independent body that on one hand works
with the hospitals and partners with
them
um to to provide that that level of care
and I've noted in several instances in
the the document the report today refers
to employed Physicians
um I don't think that captures the the
breadth of Physicians who are providing
Services inside the hospital and that
are part of the medical staff many
Physicians are that are employed are
part of the medical staff obviously but
many others who are not employed are
also part of the medical staff medical
staff executive committees made up of
doctors clinicians the hospital
Administration and many many others that
review those qualifications for
clinicians when they're initially
credentialed at the house hospital and
ultimately granting privileges for those
clinicians they review their
qualifications as they come in through a
focused provider practice and evaluation
and they continue to focus they continue
to do that on an ongoing basis so it
could be every six months it could be
every year they do have those reviews
and there's determined by the medical
executive committee the credentialing
committee or others inside the
institution how they're going to be
reviewed what metrics and all of those
things so again I think it's important
to note that they continue they are
continuously evaluated throughout their
their tenure with the the hospital
um
there's been a lot of talk about what
gets reported hospitals are required by
Statute by State Statute any facility
that is licensed under RSA 151 is
required to report any disciplinary
action taken against a clinician a
doctor a nurse a medical technician
um
and report that to the Board of Medicine
the board then has the ability and as
you heard will investigate every
instance that comes to it and we'll
choose whether they wish to make a move
I think it's you know important to
remember you know not every
complaint not every now practice
um you know settlement is and is an
admission of guilt
um and that they have somehow done the
wrong thing
um you know we refer here and we've
heard several times today lapses of
professional judgment
um you know when a situation happens it
may be
um an error occurred and if that
happened we want to identify it we want
to understand it and we want to prevent
it from happening again and there's
significant amount of effort and work
that goes into doing that just that and
if there are other circumstances
surrounding it we want to make certain
that we identify those as well every
institution in the state has a a and the
the interest of their patients and the
communities that they serve at heart and
they take those responsibilities very
very seriously and they will continue to
do so having said that we understand
that there are questions here that are
going to require some additional work
and as I said we want to continue to be
a part of that discussion and we
appreciate the opportunity to share some
much reps
Mr Allen good seeing you again different
context but um
so I I can't let go of this bone and I'm
going to ask you for your opinion on it
in those narrow cases those few cases
were the hospital for whatever reason
has decided to take action on a
physician for discipline of any kind and
it gets mandatorily reported to the
Board of Medicine as you described what
is your position what's the hospital
association's position on the board of
medicine at least echoing the action of
the hospital to the public
currently if the Board of Medicine takes
no action I'm hearing that it's not
reported even if the hospitals in your
own judgment have levied some sort of a
restriction or penalty that it isn't it
may not be reported by the Board of
Medicine is is that is the is that the
right thing or is that a a gap that we
should be worried about I think it's an
important question as I said not all
instances are created equally and so how
we just whether whether in which in
which we choose to would choose to do
that I think is the the question that we
have in front of us I don't have an
answer for you um today but I think it's
an important question that we need to to
try and uh work through
thank you
do we think that by the end of today
we're able to solve this question
or do you think that it would be a good
idea if we crafted an LSR
that would set up a group
next year
with the principal stakeholders and
different ones of us and representative
solo I pulled out of retirement
to go into quite a bit of depth on this
with the various stakeholders knowing
that they'll now have two three four
months to work up some things what do
um I I would say that
um one could go I agree full
wholeheartedly with your first
conclusion we're not going to solve this
now
I think one could do one of two things
one could either craft exactly what
you're talking about create a working
group and a study committee or
commission that your discretion
remembering always the pressure that we
will get from the speaker's office about
the use of people and how to appoint
them and all the rest of it so that's
one way you can go or uh one or more
people can file one or more lsrs and
those can have hearings and
they can either proceed as they are
drafted or be modified or be referred
for interim study or can be changed into
a study committee at that point
I was thinking that plus one of the
possibilities would be to draft an LSR
coming out of this because we will
probably have two months to craft an
amendment during which time different
ones of his cut could talk with
different people so that by the time
probably Edna takes up that bill in
early February or later we would have
done quite a bit more work and have an
amendment
is a thought
representative Solway uh thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman it is the long
practice and custom of the state
legislature to await the crafting of
lsrs to refer them to committee and to
permit the committee process to refine
and then decide if they're going to
enact statute and I would suggest that
we submit a report to the oversight
committee and that members of the
oversight committee or other members of
what will then be the newly elected
legislature determine if they wish to
okay so I I agree with everything that's
been said I just think there's a third
thing here to make it more obvious we
are trying very hard to approve a a uh a
draft or a final report on our
committee's work I think we found a hole
here uh and if we could just include the
fact that this hole exists in Professor
shalloway's report so that we don't lose
it I think it's a reportable item in
this final report that we include that
we found this Gap where hospitals do
initiate disciplinary action and the
Board of Medicine may choose not to
follow up on it and therefore the public
is unaware that that's an issue that we
should look into if we could just
include that in this final report that I
think I think we're doing what we can do
today
how do other members of this group think
about that representative Murphy I I I
think I agree with everything that has
been said I also hear from uh president
Anin and others that there is a lot of
missing information that we do not have
available currently or if we have it we
don't fully understand the ramifications
of it
so having said that I would think that
our number one goal to back up at the 50
000 foot level is to think about number
one the patient first and our goal here
is to do whatever is in is needed to be
done to make sure that the public the
patients all know who is going to take
care of them that these these providers
have the credentials the privileging and
the expertise to take care of them and
that the mechanics behind how
information is garnered within a
hospital setting in a private practice
or whatever if it's if if it's necessary
to reach the Board of Medicine for the
review that we have a fully
a fully understood process by which that
happens and I don't think we understand
that right now so whether you know as a
freshman legislator I don't understand
necessarily whether it first goes to an
LSR whether it goes to a study committee
what I do know is that my primary goal
is the patient and the safety of the
patient how we get there mechanically
legislatively I will leave to those with
more I would say more gray here but more
experience than I have
um I would add representative Murphy
that my parallel goal is to protect good
Physicians and hospitals absolutely I
was going to say that as well is that
there are a number of you know I've
practiced medicine in the state for 40
years and I can't even count on one
finger how many practitioners and
hospitals that I have dealt with at a
referral center where we received
patients from all over the state that
weren't trying to do the best thing for
their patients things go wrong in an
operating room I know that things can go
wrong in the clinic I know that but most
of the providers out there most of the
hospitals are trying to do their
darndest to make sure that quality Care
is given to the patient
there will be outliers but I want to
make sure that we don't don't lose sight
of the fact that we have a number of
great physicians in the state that are
doing their darndest and we need to
protect those even if they have a
lawsuit against them a lawsuit is
settled we still need to protect them
and I would fully support any
legislation that supports those
providers
so now so so may I crash to the 10 foot
level since we just hit 50 000
representative Whoever has to leave in
four zero minutes we we she has input
into our final report uh this is sort of
our deliverable to the day I believe
this is our deliverable uh we're not
going to save any patients today we're
just going to finish a report so if we
could maybe start focusing on what we
want in this report I don't know who
else you have to speak but I I don't
want to lose the the window of
Representative Weber's time and pod
since this is very much a work group
some of the rules that we have in normal
hearings are different
and so therefore we could move right to
discuss this report with how we wish to
tweak it and then Circle back and if
time allows uh hear from others who may
wish to give us some input so we may get
to some of you the representative Anan
do you have anything further you'd like
to add no my question was this is a
lovely venue and seat uh it's a great
sequence
but I'm not sure you need me here for
that um so if you're done with me I'll
just get back there
you're always welcome up at the hot mic
thank you thank you
representative web I want to take a stab
at it
this report the latest iteration of
Representative soloway's Report with
what probably needs to be tweaked
uh
a word Mr chairman a word I'd like to
reassure representative Weber
that her Communications were read
carefully and were if you will not
incorporated into the revision of the
document
I'm going to apologize because I didn't
see the revision of the document because
I have been somewhat inattentive to my
emails so
um would you care to share I certainly
no I will no no no no I would I would
absolutely believe my colleague when he
says he's taken them into account and
Incorporated them
I think that
you know what I've heard from others is
simply the specific issue of exploring
the
relationship between
discipline at the institutional level
and discipline at the board level uh and
I think we can simply
perhaps rely on your good nature to put
in one more sentence or possibly short
paragraph on that specific issue because
that seems to be where the nub is
um and and then state that
um you know further legislative action
will be considered by individuals at the
appropriate time
and that that would be fine with me if
that satisfies other people
Mr chairman
representative Edwards next okay so I I
agree with uh representative Weber and
as I'm looking at the paper is currently
constructed it appeals to me like we
want to add after the section on board
investigations we want to add a new
section called uh Board of Medicine
reporting
and and that and that under the The
Heading of reporting would be a very
nice place to hang this open issue that
we're not going to resolve today and
then we'd still end up closing with
Staffing and funding but we'd have a new
section four
representative soloway uh thank you Mr
chairman uh uh a couple of quick items
there are some revisions in here that
you should know about
um at Representatives Edwards insistence
uh I will change chef of medicine uh to
chief of medicine uh and we'll we'll
cook that over
um and
um a representative Weber uh and
um Ms minnehan the issue of the
statement of employed Physicians I'll go
over that but I must agree with the
discussion that
um the point on which the case turns
representative Weber to a phrase that
you're familiar with is what is
disciplinary action
where does it take place
and what of it should be reported
precise I I think we're there so I will
add as representative Edwards uh
requested a brief paragraph that speaks
to that issue uh uh how do we report
this disciplinary actions variously
defined just the final word I would like
to thank profoundly
um representative Murphy uh
representative Edwards uh the chairman
representative Weber for the substantial
work that they've put into crafting this
document my name is not on it because I
am simply the clerk for people of far
foreign
exception to that last qualification
well yeah so do we all you're voted down
on that um would you craft a couple
sentences
um and then we will take my uh title the
change of Chef to Chief although
I was hungry for more
you asked for it uh
foreign
I will say something I I can't write it
and say it at the same time if you wrote
it and then said it
well if you want to give me about three
minutes I would and I'll try at the same
time and maybe we can come up with
something
I I can almost do it orally it says I I
would say it is it appears that further
um
to resolve the issue of the differing
to resolve the issues of
the differing
no I can't do it orally yeah I'll keep
working
could the chair ask Miss minahan please
to punch up the board of medicine's
website and scroll down to board actions
and bring the computer up so I can
actually see it thank you
and if we're doing that I actually have
a question based on the fact that I've
and you wonder why I asked you to be on
foreign
if we begin with the committee
recognizes that disciplinary action
occurs at the level of Hospital review
medical staff review judicial review and
and then we need another sentence it is
therefore imperative
that any legislation
specify for the Board of Medicine
those disciplinary actions which do and
I was with you up to the
um what I was working on for the second
part of that because I like the first
part better than what I said which was
just discipline occurs at both the
institutional level and the board level
and you are far more comprehensive than
I and then I would say more explanation
is needed to determine the level at
which
uh discipline
must be reported to the Board of
Medicine disciplined by any other body
Medicine
and following
review and then I I think I just stick
with review following review at the
Board of Medicine level what
must be reported on the board of
foreign
loud and clear that we need to work on
that more
but that that's another thing uh
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman if we're tweaking this um to
some degree I would suggest that you
know the Board of Medicine I think is
their Authority is for licensing not
privileging I think that's a hospital
chore in the last paragraph
because we spoke so about the fact that
we want to protect
uh providers Physicians pas
but also nurse practitioners Etc from uh
the frivolous lawsuits and the
repercussions of that
should we not include at this point any
mention of lawsuit settlements because
it was brought up by President on and
also is that on and we also have
providers that you know May
reach the level of a suit and have it
settled but that should not necessarily
be you know Incorporated but that may be
encompassed with any you know mentions
of malpractice settlement so that's
something I think we have to ultimately
come to an agreement on as to what gets
reported I think you could take a broad
stroke and say we're going to report all
medical
malpractice settlements that may
certainly include a lot of good
providers and I think we ought to at
least table that for now
if I'm if I may we don't need to table
it I don't think because it's already
written in here in a way in which I
think you're going to be satisfied if I
could explain why on on page three the
last paragraph under investigations it
goes on to say the board shell exercise
due diligence in the next sentence it
starts to say the board shall make
public all disciplinary actions
including involuntary or involuntary
restriction of privileges large future
and fines so in your scenario where they
receive word of a frivolous malpractice
case or a case just settled out of court
to because of economy then this that
then a report of that would not get
triggered until or unless there was also
an accompanying involuntary restriction
of privileges so so although that
paragraph doesn't call out malpractice
by name it it's it's got the it's got
the safety net all underneath it because
the the things that get reported are the
ones that have resulted in voluntary or
involuntary restriction privileges
license or spines Etc
so I so I was thinking of your point
earlier today which triggered me to talk
to Dr saloway about it and and and I got
comfortable that that paragraph already
is has has the malpractice issue uh
Incorporated in it without specifically
so you're comfortable with the fact that
if you put in their exercises due
diligence that satisfies your your
concerns about having anybody reported
that may otherwise be a sound
practitioner
uncomfortable that well one we have to
trust the Board of Medicine so if as
long as they're exercising due diligence
until they see a need for restriction of
privilegious licensures and fines until
that point I could understand why it
everybody happy with what we're doing
with that paragraph
anything else we want to change tweak
add subtract I I have a few some of them
but go into the tiny
um
pick the Nets on on page
three
in the first paragraph our report
currently reads the Board of Medicine
Showplace prominently on its website a
button labeled complaint which will be
the access point for anyone who wishes
to report a complaint directly to the
board I think based on Ms Courtney's
testimony that oplc has been decided by
the legislature to to to provide the
administrative services so I would
recommend
that we strike out the the portion of
that sentence directing or you know
intending to direct that the complaint
go directly to the board because they
already there's already a process
there's a data flow so so I would delete
like directly to the board
foreign
I think in Miss Courtney's testimony she
said that a complaintant when they they
hit the submit button basically on the
Complaint Form they are notified that
the complaint has been received if if it
does not work that way I I'd like to see
that in the report that that the
complaintant should receive feedback
that their complaint has been dually
received
from
foreign
that out because we've been assured that
they are told that the complaint has
been received
I I I I just leave it open I don't I
don't know are you sure miss Courtney
that they do when they hit some some men
on the complaint that they're told that
all right in that case in that case I'd
be glad to have you put it in the report
yeah
foreign
board investigation or this new section
on Board of Medicine reporting maybe
it's the second uh the Board of Medicine
I think we should include in our
sentence that the final disposition
it doesn't sound like it is now
and then under Staffing and funding
because I'm again I want to go back to
being a retired geek I really would like
to in that that line of things that the
funding is necessary to staff its
responsibilities renumerate volunteer
Physicians I would insert in there to
mean a simple to use website I I want to
call it out that I think we've heard in
prior testimony that the website could
could use some spiffing up and that we
like the the main metaphor Maine's
Mr chairman I'd like to make a motion
representative Murphy before he makes a
motion oh thank you just a question in
the bottom of the first page the
paragraph at the bottom
um are we staying with the statement
each organization shall establish an
internal Review Committee
um I believe that that's redundant yeah
we don't need that because I do believe
there's committees in place right now
that actually do this work so all right
rather than have anybody imply that
we're establishing something new
okay thank you anybody else want to play
with the document before we have a
motion
in which case representative Solway uh
Mr chairman I would like to move that
the report to the oversight committee on
the Department of Health and Human
Services regarding the issue of
transparency and Board of Medicine
um be revised according to these
comments and remanded to the oversight
committee for its further consideration
do we have a second representative
Murphy any further discussion
oversight will next meet on the Friday
before Thanksgiving which is the third
Friday at one o'clock note the change of
date and time and what day in November
is that Friday November 18th or 18th
good
any further discussion
all in favor of accepting this report as
a member uh amended please say aye
aye opposed okay thank you very much now
we've got that in hand and going forward
in terms of lsrs they are not due until
the 22nd of November
and in the meantime I suspect there will
be two kinds of things filed one kind
will very simply establish a committee
with uh what you and I like to call The
Usual Suspects to sit on it uh to go
much further in depth if needed and then
secondly there may well be an LSR or two
that will come out tweaking the report
we've just heard it does not have to be
approved by oversight we can take the
document as revised and disseminated and
I suspect that will happen with perhaps
input during December and January before
those build that bill or those bills
wind up at Eda that's what I suspect
will go forward and
after we've gotten over
trick-or-treating maybe we can start
working on that if we feel like it
uh with that in mind we do have a few
people who are from the public and as
well as from associations and they've
asked to speak and
um I'd like to call them up do we have
Mr Jim Potter from the New Hampshire
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
for the record my name is Jim Potter I
Am the CEO of the New Hampshire Medical
Society
um and today and I would like using an
old analogy from past hearing uh kind of
backup or reiterate a couple of points
um I'm going to revise and narrow my
comments and I will send you some of
this information
um in specific I think to reiterate here
is
um uh there's been a lack of
understanding about these processes
which is clear
um and as I've said before the medical
society is committed itself and funding
to establish continuing medical
education which we officially did this
weekend this past weekend it's a
90-minute session that goes into great
depth to educate Physicians
um and I guess it will be probably
others about those processes goes into
quite a bit of depth
as I said before our greatest concern is
we had Physicians because other than a
patient dying on them
or a bad outcome this is the most
traumatic thing that will happen to a
physician in their career it doesn't
happen very often but it does happen and
so we've I have witnessed a lot of
Physicians freezing up
and and not responding as you've heard
all complaints get investigations
and Physicians who have a complaint
whether it's from an individual or a
hospital medical staff or a hospital all
those have to be responded to by that
physician often what we've seen is
Physicians would just freeze up and not
respond and so it kicks them down a
level to a very full and rigorous
Hearing in many cases wasn't needed so
that's why we want to make sure when
there's a lot of transparency going on
and just from your level of knowledge
about I think it it will be helpful for
us to take and we'll continue to revise
to simplify to make sure that these
processes are well understood by
everyone involved
because I've heard others get appear and
testify that there are the none of these
processes in place these these process
should mirror what the attorneys are
doing
and the first thing I want to reiterate
is one there is clearly a rigorous and
active investigation process for all
complaints
um brought for the board revocation in
this discipline by other states
um that and and those move forward in
the process that you kind of have the
the nice little
a chart on
um second I want to put that all medical
staff discipline
actions are reported to the board and I
think what I want to clarify I didn't
hear is the board treats those just like
a complaint those are all investigated
they require a response from a physician
so I don't see it uh respectfully I
don't see that as a whole because the
board just takes and excellent opens up
an investigation on that just like they
would any other complaint
um so it goes through that process they
could go through and say because of the
level of that we're not going to take
any action at this time now it has come
where maybe behavior elapses and repeats
itself
often I've seen a couple of those cases
where it comes back and the board does
take action on those so I don't
necessarily see it as is described as a
whole but it's just another part of the
investigation process that is required
on any complaint any action that comes
to them
um
third uh we have done some work with the
Federation of State Medical boards and
there are a number of levels there is an
analysis chart that describes what is
reported by each board and there's
there's actually 67 boards because uh
other than the the 52 kind of allopathic
ports there's another 15 osteopathic
boards in some states so there's a the
the number the the nominator is 67. and
of that number only 19 published
Hospital disciplinary actions
and again that's where there would be a
difference is the board acting on that
now we can follow up with you and we can
probably get you some of that nuanced
information what are the differences
between the states
um uh 23 uh published out of state
actions uh 25 uh publish criminal
convictions and 27 published malpractice
settlements that the board has acted on
only 27 out of 66 67 I'm sorry so I just
wanted to frame that for you because
again I think the the rush to judgment
here is well everyone else is doing this
and it's it's it's all it's all over the
place it's it doesn't happen if at some
point you would choose to say well we're
going to consider uh having malpractice
lawsuits um in there then the states of
Vermont and uh Massachusetts actually
have six conditions that they publish
right up front and say here are a number
of things you really have to consider I
won't enumerate those to you but they
they essentially are a watch that that
has been repeated often here a lawsuit
doesn't mean that they're skilled or
error that has gone into it so that's
kind of part and parcel part of the
education process if you choose to to go
in that direction
um
finally I just wanted to
um touch upon well I got those two
um I understand your report is going
forward I think I the your last point I
get item D
um and the section about funding is
necessary
um I watch as a third party I
participate in just about all the Board
of Medicine uh hearings
um I will do for the record we don't get
involved in any of the cases some states
do some states molecular societies get
and represent Physicians we choose not
to do that our focus is really on
process is the process transparent is it
working you know can we do that and so
that's where we tend to help with those
type of things and move that forward so
I often will report to the board on
various of these process issues and how
things are moving often how things are
moving here in the legislature and
whether or not they should engage on
certain issues that may or may not be
germane to them
so I think that's an important that's
something an issue on funding is
something that I've heard the board
specifically ask for for the last couple
years
um I think we've gone through a couple
part-time physician investigators
um and there hasn't been a steady staff
of attorney investigators there so I
think beefing that up through a little
financial assistance through oplc and
their request I think is a thing that
I've heard is a necessary thing that
will help essentially move processes
much more expediently as we move forward
um and and whatever you decide to do or
don't and with that I guess the other
thing I could have described myself
instead of a backup and I could have
taken from a defensive and I could have
said because of Halloween you could
consider me the monster man here
cleaning up but that's a bad joke thank
you
too much
any question any questions I I have one
I assume you've gotten the draft that
that Dr saloway has published and under
the Staffing and funding section uh this
this this is this is pretty minimalistic
and you said we should beef it up I
would just invite you if you have
alternative or additional language that
you provided specifically so that uh Dr
salowick could look at it and maybe you
know keep it in a file at least yeah
when you're talking about funding it is
not the Board of Medicine that funds
this
um all the funding quests come through
the office of professional life
insurance you know we got that but it
sounded like you you know I I just think
that there is there's professional staff
dedicated to this so a full-time
physician investigator and then probably
multiple attorney investigators that
have been requested to try to move the
case loads on an expedient basis
um uh so uh my my request is to honor
you know whatever oplc comes forward and
that hopefully reflects what the Board
of Medicine has been asking that through
the budgetary process this year so not
necessarily part of this report but part
of the budgetary
request that comes forward I would just
ask that you honor and push for that as
part of your your ongoing activities
although you may not be part of that the
chairman would like to request the
chairman of finance division three to
make sure the money gets put in the
budget
you will consider it thank you very much
it just seems to me that everything we
just said is really already in there
because uh there is uh additional
funding as necessary and there's a lot
of things in there that we seem to have
indicated or necessary so I don't think
that any further revision is required
because it's I think it's in there
thank you right
how did Nebraska do on Saturday this is
a football question Williams finally won
a game Michigan did better better
yeah in the fight of the game
thank you very much for your time I
appreciate it bye-bye chair wishes to
foreign
good afternoon my name is Melissa Hanlon
I'm an attorney at Solway and Hollis uh
here in Concord where I've had the
privilege of representing Physicians and
hospitals in malpractice cases and
Regulatory matters for the past 20 years
um I submitted my written testimony to
the members in the committee last
evening and I am mindful of your time
constraints and that some of the
material I submitted has already been
covered
so um at my own Peril I'm going to skip
ahead
um
one of the things I wanted to bring to
the table was the perspective of the
physician who's going through this
process
um and I wanted to highlight that being
named in a lawsuit or investigated by
the Board of Medicine is an incredibly
personal stressful and traumatic
experience for my clients as Physicians
I'm not saying that to minimize the
experience of plaintiffs in the process
but to emphasize that it is just as
personal for my clients as it is for the
plaintiffs Physicians went to medical
school to help people plain and simple
and we heard in Prior days that most of
the lawsuits filed are meritorious
because they've been reviewed in advance
um I think that's a misconception
um there is no statutory requirement
that plaintiff's lawyers get the case
reviewed by an expert in advance of
filing the case
there is a requirement to get to the
jury that they have a qualified expert
to testify on standard of care and
causation every year in my practice I
see cases dropped by even well-regarded
plaintiffs firms in the state because
they lack expert support so I want to
emphasize that as you consider
publicizing just the existence of a
lawsuit against a physician I think we
pretty much are a unanimous agreement we
won't
um
I also want to talk about settlements
and just emphasize that there are a
variety of reasons why Physicians cases
settled
um the first is of course the expert
feedback we get on the standard of care
and causation
um the second is what I'll call the
sympathy Factor so there are some cases
even though we have solid expert support
either the circumstances or the
plaintiff is incredibly compelling and
sympathetic and there's concerns about
bringing that to a jury
um the third is simply a business
decision so sometimes the institution or
the insurance company decides that it is
um
cost less time and money to settle a
case than to proceed to trial and I want
to emphasize also that Physicians do not
always control the decision to settle
their case and in fact it's becoming
increasingly rare for them to have a say
in that decision
um
next insurance policy limits if you have
a case where the damages are extremely
high either because the medical bills
are high or the paper the plaintiff
requires ongoing care that needs to be
funded
and the physician has a insurance policy
that has a lower limit then we have to
settle the case to protect the
physician's assets and then finally the
emotional fortitude of the physician to
participate in the litigation and trial
so all the time I have clients who say
to me you know what Melissa I can't
handle the stress of this case I really
want you to make it go away or I'm
enjoying my retirement I don't want to
deal with this or I've moved to
California I don't want to be embroiled
in a case in New Hampshire anymore
um so in other words a settlement does
not mean that the physician was
necessarily negligent let alone subject
to discipline by the New Hampshire Board
of Medicine
I included my written testimony a
detailed description of some of the
consequences for a physician of
settlements National Practitioner Data
Bank entries which can pile up if
there's discipline in the reciprocal
discipline
but I think a little-known consequence
is de-credentialing by insurance
companies so what we're seeing is
medical malpractice insurance companies
if there's discipline action or a
particularly High settlement coming in
and saying we're going to look at
whether we want this doctor on the panel
of Physicians approved to care for our
patients if you're a hospital-based
physician in a state like New Hampshire
where we have a small number of medical
insurance companies working and you get
the credentialed that's a career
um if you could wrap it up give us one
more point we'll read your testimony and
you underscore a lot of what we've been
hearing over the last three sessions so
my final point I'd like to emphasize is
that I am concerned about
um any of the changes that you folks um
decide to proceed with being implemented
on a retrospective basis rather than a
prospective basis so I think In fairness
to Physicians who have gone through this
experience this should be undertaken
prospectively and with that I'll accept
questions I think that was a very very
good point your last one any questions
representative Weber I was just going to
say I don't think we have the ability to
do it retrospectively so I think in your
report at least you're asking the board
to retrospectively publish malpractice
cases
sure could you could you be more clear
exactly which sentence you think says
that uh I did not bring my copy of the
report with me hold on all right
it would include any malpractice so it's
found in favor of the plaintiff over the
past 10 years First full paragraph first
sentence or um page two
yeah when I read that what the way I
interpreted that is to say that once
this change is in place then a 10-year
yeah I I and I heard testimony asking
you to go back and retrospectively
publish malpractice data so I did read
that to be to be oh you should you're a
lawyer okay you did say one thing that
through your whole testimony into doubt
though when you said that you knew of
people moving from New Hampshire to
California
this tweak on page two that that
sentence includes language that
demonstrates we do not mean
retrospective
it's fine that we're not looking back at
previous things it's from this point
forward I see unanimity okay we'll do
that then
rear consideration on that point
seeing none thank you very much and
we can't hear you up here
time would it be okay with returning
Julie Kirkland came up with attorney
names sure look I found out last Friday
we have a lot of microphones so if you
want to come up and find one that has
little red buttons you can come up at
this point you can come up too if you
want
attorney Hayes if you feel like it you
know okay go and I will let attorney
Kirkland go first if I know you may do
that provided quite a bit of testimony
to the committee already all right well
good afternoon thank you my name is
Kimberly Kirkland I'm a lawyer at rice
and Kirkland in Manchester I live here
in Concord I was a faculty member at the
UNH formerly Franklin Pierce Law Center
School of Law for 15 years where I
taught civil procedure and legal ethics
and actually taught law students about
the attorney discipline process and
malpractice suits against attorneys and
those kinds of things my firm now does
plaintive smell practice work and I
think given where the discussion has
gone gone today I I would just
um jump in and respectfully say I think
that the changes you're talking about in
this recommend station you're making
would not have changed what happened
with Dr Baraboo
I don't see anything in that document
that would change what happened as I
understand it there were 21 lawsuits
filed and perhaps more lawsuits were
filed against Dr barabo and I'd say by
the way Holly represented some
plaintiffs in those cases I didn't have
any of those cases so I'm not talking to
you as an advocate
for those particular patients but as I
understand it there were claims made 21
of them were settled the only reason we
know that there were 21 claims that were
strong enough to be settled is because
they were reported in the National
Practitioner Data Bank and Massachusetts
made that information available to
Massachusetts
patients consumer citizens but we don't
know the specifics of those cases we
don't but it could be anything but I
really take issue with this idea
presented that settled lawsuits
represent frivolous claims I don't think
anyone here said that we said that some
of them do some of them are heroic
actions where the patient died but still
there was no guilt involved and some of
them were we very carefully each session
of this committee broke out those 3 in
terms of malpractice and what I kept
saying is from the Massachusetts website
I can't tell which is which
uh that's true
um I would say that I think patients
have a right to have that information
when they're making decisions about who
their doctor should be but if you assume
that out of those 21 lawsuits at least
some of them had Merit how is it that
the New Hampshire Board of Medicine did
not find its way to discipline Dr barabo
in any but one of those cases there's
something happening there's a problem at
the New Hampshire Board of Medicine in
terms of the efficacy of their
investigations and it may be a result of
problems in terms of personnel and
funding and process but I can tell you
in the claims that I bring we used to
see requests from the Board of Medicine
when I filed a lawsuit in Superior Court
and the Superior Court then transferred
that complaint the Board of Medicine we
would get a communication from the Board
of Medicine asking us to have our
clients sign a medical authorization
consistent with HIPAA that would allow
the board to collect their medical
records let me interrupt on this before
you go past this point of the 20 that
the Massachusetts board reported then
there's one more apparently and there
seemed to be some discipline at CMC
wouldn't the next complaint go to oplc
well I then would investigate it and
kick it to Board of Medicine but as I
understand
well
CMC didn't report well let me share it
I think they're talking about a specific
case he wasn't in existence during
several of those matters
um so I just wanted to clarify that
for chair right
I'm getting a little uncomfortable I I
don't believe we should be using a
specific individual's name we're here to
look at process uh we're not
um but it's I don't believe it's
appropriate for us to uh continue any
further Dialogue on an individual
scenario other than the fact that we can
generically refer to some procedural or
process questions that may arise but I
if we could avoid using names the chair
appreciates that thank you very much we
can as we've been trying to do say it
seems there have been certain things
that might have risen to the level of
but where did they wind up ever being
dealt with that's what we're trying to
figure out we're not adjudicating any
specific things against an individual
we're trying to see if a process needs
to be tweaked or and I wasn't trying to
suggest adjudicating anything against
any individual but I appreciate it we
have examples of
situations where Hospital credentialing
committees did not make reports our
Challenge on the naming of people is
that we have the Press here and I don't
think it's appropriate to reintroduce a
physician's name again into a media
environment that's why I'm asking us to
just you're doing it now but let's just
stick to the process questions all right
my process question is your
recommendation suggests that you are
going to rely heavily on reporting by
Hospital credentialing committees as a
way of triggering information to the
Board of Medicine and the Board of
Medicine then following up with
investigations and I'm not clear that
even
now that hospitals who do have a
requirement that they mandatorily report
discipline if they've formally
disciplined a physician as I understand
it they're required to report to the
Board of Medicine okay there's a period
in there go ahead
for Kirkland
um welcome
you will note within this document being
an attorney I'm sure you've read it
carefully that there is provision for
complaints to be heard and for
responsible reporting by chief medical
officers
presidents of medical staff
a physician colleagues that's all built
in
so
not only do complaints go under this
document to the Board of Medicine from
hospitals but also from Physicians staff
and uh the regulating staff the medical
staff at the hospital
those are all already built in and I
think you would probably find in reading
this document that it's not just the
hospital's responsibility it's the
professional's responsibility and we've
covered that and is there some
teeth to that in terms of getting
a chief of a medical staff or a
physician colleague to report a
colleague to the Board of Medicine as
you know you're Adept at this this is
not yet even an LSR let alone a statute
and that remains to be drafted of course
however the verbiage is those Physicians
shall report not should not May it's
shall and it remains for the very Adept
legislators on the oversight committee
and in the House and Senate to draft
legislation that contains appropriate
disciplinary action if those reports are
not leveled thank you
um all right well assuming if you assume
that reports are going to be coming from
those folks that you've just identified
the Board of Medicine has to be equipped
to do adequate investigations and we are
not seeing
investigatory work we're not seeing
requests for authorizations for medical
records coming anymore from the Board of
Medicine this is why one of the last
paragraphs talks about adequate funding
when bom was here they said that they
they do the best they can but they're
just not staffed sufficiently so we
intend to deal with that problem so it
would could not be in the future cited
as a reason for a lack and and I think
we would argue that it would behoove the
process to consider having professional
investigators both physician and lawyer
investigators as was suggested earlier
who could fulfill that function
okay last Point yes please go ahead
thank you very much Sharon and thank you
representative saloway for all of your
work on this document and the entire
committee it's an excellent First Step
um
respectfully
my difficulty with this document is that
it essentially codifies existing law
there are only two changes that I can
see and one would be if
physician Hospital discipline is
reported on the website and two would be
if malpractice cases were reported on
the website
but how the document is drafted right
now
um it says judicial findings of
malpractice or a malpractice finding in
favor of a plaintiff
99 of malpractice cases
resolve outside of court so there's not
a Judicial finding of malpractice
there's not a finding in favor of
plaintiff medical malpractice cases are
you that resolve out of court usually
have neither party docket markings
saying that neither party won so that's
how the majority of them pay out and I
just respectfully wonder if
what you may have intended for that
provision is the payments by the
National Practitioner Data Bank that
we've been discussing that Massachusetts
reports as opposed to the malpractice
claims itself when there is a payment on
behalf of a physician
with regard to the existing law though
respectfully the this committee was
formed to
in response to a specific issue and
that was the trigger we have become
aware there could have been other
triggers this one happened to be the one
that did it but it could have been
otherwise yes thank you very much
um and respectfully with all of the
reporting mechanisms that are already in
place our concern is that this isn't
going to change anything because there
are no teeth the previously there were
mandatory reporting mechanisms by
Statute or hospitals of all discipline
disciplinary conduct that is in the
statute RSA 151 by courts by insurance
companies
um respectfully if all of this had
happened in the past we know based on
what was published there were at least
five public lawsuits against one
position we know that there was a
hospital report of discipline against
the same physician we know that at least
one New Hampshire attorney drafted a
letter to the Board of Medicine about
the same physician
at the point if the National
Practitioner Data Bank is reporting
payments at the same time they would
have reported before 2017 at least five
payments and in 2020 and 2021 they would
have reported the additional 17 payments
um
insurance companies at the same time
should have been reporting their
reserves if you look on the Board of
Medicine website and this is one
question you were looking at there are
guidelines published for Hospital
reporting that's already on that website
there's a specific document for
guidelines for reporting there's also a
specific document
um
toward directed to insurance companies
because they are not reporting as
they're supposed to they are not
complying with the statute and they
aren't reporting reservable claims so
respectfully I
think that had
all of the reporting requirements been
followed had the board been doing its
job when all of these reports were made
we would never have gotten to this point
because by the time the hospital was
taking discipline in 2013
it should have been acted on by the
Board of Medicine the chair wonders
allowed
um if perhaps some of these things is
not the scope of the Attorney General's
office's investigation that's ongoing at
present time
and I'm unfamiliar with that
investigation I learned about that today
for the first time which I was very
pleased to hear that it is ongoing it is
representative soloway
councilor hey it's nice to see you again
um I have a legal question to which I
don't have any answer but I suspect you
do what kinds of limitations are imposed
on publication by non-disclosure
agreements and how do we get ourselves
past that that as as drafted this
document that was a real conundrum for
this non-non attorney
so the the non-disclosure agreements I
presume that you mean
if that you're cutting published
settlements if there's an insurance
element and there's a non-disclosure
agreement
how do we get around that if we want to
make that public and so I don't think
that you can you can publish that a
lawsuit was filed in court we've heard
the difficulties with that or the issues
that might arise but you could also
publish the information that
Massachusetts publishes just the fact
that a payment was made and the date
that the payment was made and the
position there are no facts about the
malpractice that are included even if
these are non-disclosure agreement you
get the option to payment was made
that's all information that's contained
within the National Practitioner Data
Bank that's reported to the Board of
Medicine already within 30 days of when
it's reported every insurance company is
required to report to the National
Practitioner Data Bank if they make a
payment on behalf of a physician and
they reported the National Practitioner
Data Bank then reports it to the Board
of Medicine a quick follow-up quick
follow-up can you imagine the reluctance
of non-attorneys On The Board of
Medicine to publicize if there is a
non-disclosure agreement not really
knowing what the legal Turf is
I can't understand that but
non-disclosure agreements are generally
limited to the specific case they're
usually
very artfully crafted stating that you
can't disclose the names of the parties
the doctor the hospital the conduct
specifically the court or the settlement
terms those are the usually the parts of
the non-disclosure agreement there's
nothing that says
that you can publish what is already a
public document in Superior Court the
fact that a case was filed or what is
contained in the National Practitioner
Data Bank the fact that a payment was
made on behalf of the physician none of
that would violate a non-disclosure
agreement the other issues would this is
where I repeat my statement that the
Massachusetts board's reporting was
either too much information or not
enough information because all I see is
settlement settlement settlement
settlement I do not know how many were
frivolous how many were heroic but not
bad medicine the patient died because
most of them were going to die anyway
somebody stepped up and went in Where
Angels Fear to operate and then how many
of them were bad I can't tell so then
don't tell me what you told me because
you've told me half a story so that
comes back to if there is a
settlement where there is also
disciplinary action we need to know
about that and I would say nothing less
than that but nothing more that's what
we're trying to get
okay
um I got two minutes to wrap it up thank
you very much
um it does not include you're asking the
question so would you ask your question
you know I I I I was almost an attorney
so I I appreciate that you guys are so
comfortable in what feels like an
adversarial situation here and I I'm
going to try to just ask you some
process questions I'm just a geek trying
to build a machine okay
um so I got four questions uh
if when when a person files a
malpractice case
uh and that judicial decision comes over
to the board of medicine do you believe
that there's enough identifiable
information of who the complaintance was
that we could possibly use that
information on the suit in order to
contact them to let them know what the
resolution of the case was absolutely
the complaint that's filed with the
court in order to establish jurisdiction
the parties there and their address
their residential address have to be
published in that document okay so the
Board of Medicine would not have a
problem figuring out who the actual
human was that filed the complaint not
at all it would be on page one or page
two of the complaint second question
um
I'm confused now because it sounds like
we we believe that in the statute that
there's mandatory reporting of you know
disciplinary actions by the hospitals
and the like
um but I'm hearing something contrary or
it sounds like you're implying that they
don't have to report because there's no
teeth in this system and so this is
surprising to me I would think that they
would be mandate mandatory reporters
um I can tell you that there is
mandatory reporting required by the
statute but I suspect it's how the
internal committees are created that
they can couch any review in the terms
of credentialing or quality assurance or
privilege of some sort I know that there
are physicians in the room who are
waiting to testify who may be able to
speak more to that um okay the the
comment I'm hearing from you that I'm
trying to feed is
um if if if there's no if there's not
enough teeth in the statute I could use
some specific specific language with
your finger in the statute saying this
is weak It should read this way I I the
board is already or the committee's
probably ready to do its final report
but I would like to know that
information the the
um if you if you want to share that as
you're invited to
um you you I think one of you have
implied that the Board of Medicine has
some difficulty getting the records it
would need in order for them to do an
adequate investigation to make a
determination of discipline or is there
is there a problem with our statute
where the Board of Medicine can't get
the information they need to do a real
investigation I I don't want to mishear
you no I don't think that's the problem
at all I believe what attorney Kirkland
was referring to was years ago when
there was an administrative prosecution
unit there was an investigator who would
reach out to the council for the
plaintiffs in every malpractice suit
asking for their client to sign
authorizations to access the medical
records since the administrative
prosecution unit has been dissolved
there are no requests coming to
plaintiff's attorneys and um it's not
the statute it sounds to me like we've
fallen down in terms of our
infrastructure our human infrastructure
and respectfully representative I think
that's the whole problem that may have
been the Genesis of this Committee in
the first place it's just that
we've fallen down in oversight of the
Board of Medicine and what it's actually
doing and and
a large part of that is resources as
you've heard they need more resources
but a large part of it too is just that
they aren't doing the investigations
they should be doing well because we'll
wait what the internal General says and
we will make sure we get some money in
the budget and then I have a fourth
question
um
okay at this point the Board of Medicine
as I understand it receives every
malpractice case
they are required to investigate every
single one they make an independent
determination of whether or not they
should want to impose some kind of a
disciplinary action on that physician
based on the malpractice case before
them
uh and presumably if they're competent
in doing the right thing if they say
that there should be disciplinary action
then it is in fact reported but in their
an issue that should be reported they
don't Levy disciplinary action that
that's the processes I understand it I I
think I was hearing you say that that's
not enough that that that just the
receipt of a malpractice case as long as
it maybe meets these six tests by
Vermont it ought to be reported but what
is wrong with the New Hampshire way of
having that independent thought put into
it and they design deciding
independently if they should impose
discipline and it's the discipline that
by the board that triggers the reporting
is or is that is that a pro is that
problematic to to either of you
um I would say the problem is that I
don't think the board has what it needs
to do an adequate investigation there
was some discussion earlier about
plaintiff's lawyers and what we do to
comb through the thousands of calls that
come to us to decide what we could
really prove in court was a practice
below what you would expect from your
average physician in that specialty and
it takes us hours and hours of time
reviewing medical records and hiring
expensive experts and although we're not
required by law to do that before we
file suit we'd be crazy not to do it
before we file soon and it looks to us
from what we can tell happens to the
cases that we file and then what happens
with the board that they just don't have
the adequate personnel and time and I'm
not sure what else is happening but it's
not happening they're not doing those
kinds of thorough reviews in our our
view I I think we may have stumbled on
some violent agreement because on our
last paragraph here
implies it's it could it's a little
minimal in the way it says it and the
emphasis it puts on it but I think we
understand that there is a staffing and
financing issue here that needs to be
looked at and the people that have to go
first in the process is oplc they need
to you know tell the governor what they
need Governor needs to agree with them
got to send it over to the legislature
so so the first step in the I think I
think we understand that and we want to
fix that but but there's you know other
people have to do things we're repeating
ourselves here several times so
thank you I am now going to take the
last two speakers and you will have five
minutes no more each thank you chairman
and please don't plow the ground that
and you got five minutes
thank you Mr chairman
um
members of the committee thank you for
your time really addressing patient
safety and quality of care it's so
important and I appreciate what you're
doing my name is Dr Roy Fami I've served
in Bears leadership positions in
multiple health systems for over a
decade and I just like to address the
fundamental issue of information flow
and it's really regarding the
disciplinary actions that are taken
against a medical staff member
originating from the institution or the
health system this is from my
perspective only please understand that
but in my experience in observations
institutions tend to fault heavily to
the New Hampshire statute of 15113 on
the proceedings of Hospital committees
confidentiality to really filter some of
that information concerning disciplinary
actions to the appropriate regulatory
bodies and that may be one of the
fundamental issues of the inflammation
that's not getting to where it needs to
go
and I guess my questions are can the
statute be bolstered to mandate the
institution to report and how is the
institution held accountable for the
lack of reporting for these disciplinary
actions
thank you
and last is Lori
Nepal
okay
thank you for letting me speak
I had grandchildren over the weekend I'm
not used to people hearing me
thank you welcome so my name is Lori
nerbon I'm a nurse um who is uh in
charge of a small non-profit called New
England patient voices it used to be New
Hampshire patient voices
I work as a patient advocate often
listening to Patient complaints or
patient issues that they've had in
hospitals
from 2008 to 2012 I coordinated public
testimony for patient safety legislation
here about infection reporting and
adverse event reporting
what I would like to stress to this
committee is we've talked a lot about
the the weeds and the details of
legislation and policies but we are here
I just want to remind you that we are
here to achieve the board's mission of
safeguarding the public
one of the patient testimonials that I
coordinated back in 2009 for the adverse
event reporting bill was a woman whose
husband died after surgery by Dr barabow
we're not using names here okay
um
transparency by way of State legislation
has a direct impact by increasing public
attention increasing funding research
and most important prevention of what
brought us here today
all of us here know about health care
infections now but back in 2004
they were considered just an unavoidable
consequence of being a hospital ICU
now we know hospitals have gotten some
of them to zero mandates and public
pressure work
although I see myself as an advocate for
all patients I'm also here today as a
nurse who has specialized in patient
safety since the death of my mother
more recently as a nurse patient
advocate in acute care hospitals in
Massachusetts investigating and
processing patient complaints many of
which involve physician and quality of
care issues
with and without patient injuries
for one of those years I coordinated
quality improvement projects in
hospitals and nursing homes across New
England under a contract with Medicare
and Medicaid
I just am here today to impress upon
this panel and all legislators the vital
role you play in patient safety
as you may know medical harm and
injuries are at the very least the third
leading cause of death in America
multiple Studies have validated this and
a reason oig report for the second time
calculated that preventable medical
medical harm to Medicare patients alone
is 15 000 per month
this is not to ignore Medical Care is
Advanced and performs miraculous care
for many of the vast majority of Health
Care profession and the majority of
Health Care Professionals strive every
day to achieve the highest standards of
care
but regulatory oversight as well as
state and federal laws play the most
important role in preventing patient
harm
they have the power to require that
Health Care Facility leaders
follow well-established laws and
guidelines and I think if there's one
thing to stress today
the issue that we're dealing with is
that there wasn't a following of the
guidelines whether it was the Board of
Medicine or whether it was hospitals or
whoever that's what we need to get to
the bottom of
that
that a patient who was being operated on
in New Hampshire didn't have available
to them the information they needed to
make an informed decision
one thing I want to point out that
hasn't been mentioned today is the
National Practitioner Data Bank does not
allow Boards of medicine to publish
anything any information about lawsuits
or settlements on their website
so in order to do that like
Massachusetts does we need a state
mandate to do that
and I know that the committee has also
decided not that you're not going to
post settlements but I think it's
important that
in the process of
a hospital credentialing committee or
whoever is looking into looking at
physician licensing they go to the
National Practitioner databank to look
at that information so does the Board of
Medicine that's where they get it from
so unless and I the attorney spoke to
how there is a lapse in how the medical
board is getting information about
lawsuits
and there is an enormous lapse
or settlements there's an enormous lapse
in
when a Haas it first of all our
hospitals reporting disciplinary actions
to the board
who's auditing that how often is it
happening and how often is is it not
happening
and the other important thing is to know
about the loopholes that are often used
to not report and that would be that
they may decide you've got two minutes
to finish up thank you that they may
decide to only discipline a physician
for 28 days if if the requirement is
that it has to be 30 days
so you point to chapter and verse on
where 30 days is said so this is with
the National Practitioner databank I
what I would like is a point of
clarification from the medical board
about what their requirement is is it
all disciplinary actions get reported to
them
or is it only a certain length of
disciplinary action or loss of
privileges I don't know that and I
pardon me
do we do we know the answer to that I
think it's an important point so if it's
if it's it has to be 30 days yeah
it's any disciplinary action
okay it's a yes or no if if there was
discipline then yes if not reported
to the board so it's not like the
National Practitioner Data Bank
requirement
I just want to leave you with when
patients and their families make the
difficult decision to have surgery
they're placing their life and
well-being and not only the surgeon's
hands but Hospital administrators who
are ultimately responsible for the safe
practices in their facility
they are compensated well to put patient
safety ahead of all else and we need to
be clear
that in a case of 14 deaths eight within
one summer and 21 lawsuits
this was not a one-off this was not two
or three honest mistakes hospitals have
entire teams of patient safety
professionals dedicated to measuring
every surgeon's outcomes
they track complications Adverse Events
infections and deaths and data doesn't
lie
it would have been virtually impossible
for the surgeon not to be a serious
outlier
if you have not already had the chance I
urge you to read The Whistleblower
lawsuit
it's very revealing and details the
specifics of the medical care that was
provided
I hope you agree that when bad things
happen and the public safety is at stake
it is all of our responsibility to do
what we can to ensure it doesn't happen
again
we can't ignore or forget that multiple
doctors and nurses inside the system
sounded the alarm
as a nurse I can't imagine how it felt
to work every day knowing their concerns
were not being addressed knowing another
patient would likely be harmed or die
under their watch it's demoralizing it's
why wonderful people leave health care
and it's also why patients Sue it's the
only way they can get answers
you can provide written documentation
sure yes you can but thank you so much
my final word to anybody listening in if
you want
to give us input
please don't give us the big overview of
how the procedures work and hospitals
function and so on we know that stuff
we've heard it many times but
don't but what we are asking is give us
specifics don't tell us the law should
change tell us which law by line item
should change how
we're not going to plow through big
documents that tell us all kinds of
generalizations we know that stuff
you want us to make some changes
tell us what laws what procedures and
then give us suggested other language
and we'll listen to that stuff because
although our report has been accepted
and is being turned into oversight next
month
I suspect there's going to be a couple
of lsrs written either to establish a
much more in-depth committee or to
establish some changes in procedure so
that is what we need is specific stuff
so thank you everyone thank you
committee it's been great thank you
representative Solway for taking all of
our stuff and turning it into a good